c'est un événement qui se décline sur
niveau national et des événements dans
toute la france au niveau national on a
cette année comptabilisé 273 événements
et nous en martinique on a cinq
événements qui se déroulent sur la
semaine donc dans le cadre de la semaine
de l'innovation publique c'est à dire
qu'il s'agit d' de mettre en avant
toutes les démarches d'innovation
des démarches des collectivités les
démarches administrations qui sont
innovantes pour aller vers le citoyen
aller vers le public
alors sur le terrain ben on a des
événements qui ont été relayés par par
les opci
qui sont notamment l'espace sud qui est
donc à communiquer autour de lui
l'espace sud à une semaine assez chargé
ils ont des événements un petit peu
envers leurs élus et envers leur
communauté au sein de l'amphithéâtre de
l'espad sud mais ils ont des événements
aussi comme des ateliers timone des
ateliers grand moun qui se déroule à
ducos au saint-esprit à rivière salée
on a aussi cap nord qui fait un
événement
unique demain qui est un plateau télé
qui est surtout de la matinée qui va
diffuser dans les mines dans le cadre de
ces médias internet média de cap nord et
puis après on a un autre événement
assez assez grand public aussi qui
organisait par par open it on peut dit
une association qui dynamise un petit
peu le numérique sur le territoire
envers les entreprises mais dans le cas
de la semaine de l'innovation c'est
surtout une animation plus large donc
ils ont deux jours d'animations le jeudi
le vendredi 24 et le samedi 25 à la
cyberbase des trois ilets avec
classement de l'atelier un travail sur
les objets connectés nous la préfecture
on va présenter une plateforme de télé
clarations de télédéclaration des
événements sportifs pour les
associations sportives
voilà un petit peu les événements
j'en ai cité 3 à prendre à deux
événements un peu plus fermé qui sont
qui sont pas ouverts au public mais mais
et qui sont donc un événement de la ctm
les archives départementales qui qui va
donc ça c'est un événement qui est
vendredi midi sur invitation qui va
mettre en avant des seniors qui ont
travaillé sur la bnp m qui est la banque
numérique du patrimoine martiniquais
donc un site internet dans lequel on a
on retrouve des oeuvres du patrimoine
martiniquais qui ont été scannées mis en
ligne et ces personnes ont participé à
indexer à travailler sur les oeuvres de
manière à indexer à faciliter les
recherches sur ce site et nous la
préfecture on va aussi jeudi dans le
cadre du comité des usagers c'est une
réunion qui se tient chaque année avec
des associations d'usagers on va
présenter la borne les points numérique
qui ont été installés en préfecture sont
des points qui ont été mis en accès au
public sur ce qu'on a nous une
transformation numérique qui se fait au
niveau national qui est la ppn j'ai le
plan préfecture nouvelle génération
c'est à dire qu'en fait dans le cadre
des régions en france qui ont été
fusionnées il ya eu des réorganisations
donc même si nous on n'est pas une
région fusionner on profite de cette
organisation et notamment aujourd'hui
tous les titres permis de confirmer de
conduire et
et cartes grises sont maintenant ne sont
plus l'idée livrés par des guichets mais
sont délivrées sans demander directement
sur sur les sites internet donc on a des
points numériques qui seront présentés
joly